Đây là tử thách, đây là tử thách năm, nương sức tử quẩn năm,
cho thẳng đi là tử thách đi vào tử năm,
ở đi là tử thách.
Y伙 như là chio của nương sức tử,
cũng chính là chio của vết tơ cảm ứng từ vết.
Vết tơ cảm ứng từ vết,
phía tuy của nương sức tử, có chio phíao chio của nương sức tử.
Y伙 thấy là vết tơ cảm ứng từ vết không,
và tử thách đồng tử quẩn năm chio.
Rồi năm chio chuyển đó,
bây giờ là rân,
không dây,
đồng lên cảm ứng từ vết tơ,
không từ vết,
xem cái tử thông xác,
không không bao băng lên,
thì nó chung mạnh kinh,
nó có có ra rời,
chia xuống dạm mô ràng liè,
cảm ứng,
bây giờ,
chia xuống dạm,
cảm ứng ràng liè,
nó từ thông,
bây giờ,
rân liè,
cảm ứng,
cảm ứng này,
đường nhạc nhạc.
Rân liè,
cảm ứng,
là lạc đi,
xuống dạm,
chung không dây,
sẽ xinh ra mô tâm chio mời,
rồi nó tư chường cảm ứng,
tư chường cảm ứng này,
nó chứ bởi mẹ tư chạm,
tư chường cảm ứng,
có chio,
ông chung lại,
nguyên nhé,
bởi mẹ tư chường cảm ứng,
tư chường cảm ứng,
câu chio dư,
anh ơi,
xí, đây!